welcome to this complete youtube
strategy master class where i'm going to
be breaking down three frameworks that
are going to help you succeed on youtube
this year and specifically find your
unique niche you might be wondering what
should i actually make my channel about
how to stand out from the competition
and also our mastery framework for how
to rapidly learn the new skills that you
need when it comes to succeeding on
youtube and so it's actually three
different sessions and if you're
watching this replay you can check out
time codes and chapters to see these
trainings in the first session it's all
about how to find the best channel topic
for you that gets money that gets views
and earns money and it's our three p
framework then in the second session
we're gonna be sharing the unfair
advantage framework you might be feeling
right now like man there's so much
competition on youtube how do i stand
out how do i find my unique spot that's
exactly what you're going to learn in
this second session and then finally in
the third session we're going to be
talking about the rapid skill
development framework that you can use
to quickly master the necessary skills
for growing to a hundred thousand
subscribers and beyond and if you're new
here this is the grow with video live
show and so weekly we're coming to you
on the countdown to our event that's
happening online and in las vegas called
grow with video live and i'll tell you a
little bit more about that
later as we get ready and get into the
main content of today's show
[Music]
welcome back to the grow with video live
show i'm excited because today i am
joined by the incontrovertible miss
heather taurus and omar el tacori from
the think media team heather how's it
going and what are you sipping on today
oh my goodness i am just so excited sean
uh especially for this content
specifically because this is what we get
asked all the time when we're coaching
students in our video ranking academy
where we are helping uh smart
entrepreneurs figure out what they
should be making content about so i am
so excited that we're giving this away
for free here on uh the growth video
live show and the countdown is on sean
we are getting closer and closer to it
i'm sipping on water out of a mason jar
yes i am a millennial and this is what
we do so how about you omar what are you
excited about
no i like you know just like heather
said i i don't believe we ever shared
this like publicly and it's crazy that
this uh what shawn's gonna teach i know
it's going to help you
you can go ahead and put free game in
the comments free game because that's
what we're all about and i just got done
drinking a water bottle and i crushed
the water bottle and then threw it in
the trash can
uh i'm in san diego right now they
didn't have recycling so if you're if
you're about that green life i'm sorry
but
i love her over here and i'm excited
because of course heather and omar are
uh lead content creators on the think
media team and we're gonna be doing some
q a with you live here in between our
three sessions but i want to get
straight to the content and the
overarching class today is our youtube
strategy 2022 really master class three
sessions on how to find your unique
niche and stand out from the competition
and in session number one we're talking
about how to find the best channel topic
for you specifically that gets views and
earns money and what i need you to do
right now is maybe suspend
a little bit of of the
prior mindsets you've had about what
your youtube channel should be about and
tell me in the comments or here live
what actually is your current channel
topic what is your channel about
and this framework is really for you if
you would say sean i actually want to
make youtube my full-time job and if
that's true if you want to make a
full-time living from youtube or 2x or
5x or 10x your business revenue using
youtube you have to be willing i think
to potentially change your channel topic
or pivot your channel topic you can't
just say i want to do things the way i
want to do it's the way i feel about it
and i just want it to be successful
using this framework where help will
help you do really two things not only
get views but also earn money so if you
would say sean my ambition is to
actually find the right topic for me
that will do all of those things that's
what this is all about and this is
called our 3p framework and today we're
really going to be going deep into like
you might want to pull out a journal and
shut out distractions this is like a
master class and this is how we
recommend if you'd say sean i don't know
what to make my channel topic about or
are you like me and you're
multi-passionate right you're also like
i've kind of i've narrowed it down
to seven things there's seven potential
topics or right now maybe you're
actually doing seven different things on
your channel i think this is really
going to help you if you would say what
should my niche be about what should my
channel be about and the first thing i
want you to do is draw three circles
intersecting just like this and in the
first circle write the first p which is
passion see this is kind of the dream of
today is they say wow now it's time to
cash in on your passion gary vaynerchuk
wrote a book about it in 2009. what are
you passionate about do what you love
and you'll never work another day in
your life actually
i think that's bad advice but we'll get
back to that in a second
you kind of want to start with passion
because you really want to be sold on
okay
what are some things i'm passionate
about that i could see myself interested
in for the next couple years and here's
what i want you to do using this
framework is not only write passion in
the first circle but what i want you to
do is i want you to brainstorm five to
ten different passions you could make a
youtube channel about now if you already
know what your youtube channel is about
i want you to do this anyways because
this might give you clarity for the next
step in your journey and it might even
be
a strategic pivot that your channel
needs to make to achieve more success so
what you might do is you might write
down okay
uh i'm passionate about guitar here's
some for me i'm passionate about
snowboarding i'm passionate about video
i'm passionate about leadership i'm
passionate about the bible like i could
write down different things so your goal
is to not be judgmental of yourself or
or even of the passions or question
whether they'd be successful or not the
first thing is to just brainstorm so
pull out a piece of paper just start
brainstorming down what are you know
four five six ten different passions
that you have
but then what we're going to want to do
is go on to the next p which is
proficiency which is proficiency
and now this is asking what topic would
establish you as an authority with the
least amount of effort
what are you good at what is a natural
skill for you what do you have the most
experience in and so proficiency what
we're going to do here is we're going to
be layering these on top of each other
these three p's
and we're looking for thematic overlap
so when i think about okay here's me
doing the exercise um snowboarding
pretty good
uh but not amazing like i i fall i've
injured myself i can kind of rip but you
put me in the park on rails and jumps
i'm not gonna do very good there okay
guitar
uh i am a great singer and guitar player
in my own mind um when the shower is on
or when the music speakers are blaring
loud but as soon as the music sp is the
radio speakers in my car off my wife
sonya is like this is not your gift sean
this is not your proficiency
right so you wanna soberly evaluate now
your five to ten passions to which ones
are you most proficient at now i could
say video and even back when i started
youtube
in 2010 and uploaded my first video
i
realized that i already had seven years
experience in video
i started shooting videos from my local
church in 2003.
so videos on there like okay not only am
i passionate about this but i also watch
i have some experience in this i have
some proficiency in this i have some
history in this it's also something that
has kept me curious
it makes me also think about which what
what have you maybe read a lot of books
about or or studied about what kind of
content you research on youtube and it
keeps you fascinated and so i'm
interested in actually not just video
but online business marketing leadership
and kind of things that relate towards
being an influencer how do i be a
communicator things like that so i go
okay well i can maybe scratch out
snowboarding i'm going to scratch out
guitar
i'm going to scratch out and i'm maybe
in a circle video so what i want you to
do
is you've written down five to ten
passions but now you're putting them
through a second filter which is the
proficiency filter
okay
and you maybe narrow it down to two or
three or four more that you have a
little bit of experience in and i don't
want you to be overly judgmental like do
not say about yourself like i'm just not
good at anything that's not true
like i even look back now and in 2010
when i started think media
i just had some experience in video i
had to keep learning and growing and
that's what today's third session is
about during this youtube strategy
master class i couldn't have stayed
where i was in that skill but the cool
thing about proficiency is you just have
to be one or two steps ahead of the
person that you want to help on youtube
and you're good because someone's always
starting someone's always beginning and
so sometimes you're overly critical of
yourself and i want you to be honest
like what do you have some momentum in
you you have a little experience in but
it brings us to the third p and that's
profit and that is profit now if you
want to do youtube as a hobby well then
you don't need this p but if you want
this to be a real business you want to
tap into the 5x growth that's coming to
the creator economy in the next nine
months you want this to be something
that sustains you and your family so you
could do what you want when you want be
your own boss and really actually have
significant revenue coming in you have
to take this p serious okay so this p is
the profit p and this is asking the
question of is there a market for this
this is asking the question of what's
the business model this is asking the
question of how am i actually going to
make money and can i make money and will
people pay me for this
and so now i might look through and
maybe i narrowed it down to leadership
which is a great niche and i'm like okay
i've been a youth leader for a while
this back in 2010 i'm doing this i'm
right snowboarding that's not gonna be
it guitar definitely not it video maybe
leadership okay
uh that would be maybe good too but then
i move over to profit then i can start
asking myself okay
what what are the income streams going
to be could i do affiliate marketing and
talk about cameras and tech well that's
actually the way i originally made a
six-figure income and was able to do
this full-time okay that's a cool way to
make money if leadership-wise what am i
going to do
i don't know could i make an online
course sure could i write a book yeah it
might be kind of hard though and it's
easier to start with affiliate marketing
okay great so i'm just kind of
brainstorming now watch you've written
down five to ten passions narrowed it
down to like three or four of those that
are you're proficient at but now you're
asking which one is best
to earn money
and that's going to give you your best
path to
a profitable youtube channel that you
could go full time at but now i have
some warnings for you and these three
big mistakes that people make and the
first one is if all you have though
is passion and proficiency but there's
not a solid market for it or you haven't
established a solid business model then
friend all you're going to have is a
hobby
you this is why it's the 3p framework
you need all three p's and you need to
dial in your knit your youtube channel
topic around these
because if you only have the two p's you
have a hobby again if you would say sean
that's my goal i just kind of want to
share my message online i kind of want
to inspire people i don't care if i make
money or not it's not going to be a
business well then at least have that
self-awareness and clarity but if you
want this to be something solid you need
the profit p and not just the passion
and proficiency p
the thing is though you also might say
okay when i look at proficiency and
profit i feel like those are dialed in
but this idea that i have right here i
don't know how passionate about it i am
in that case you might be in boredom
and and the thing with
when i think about youtube i like to ask
myself if i'm going to start a channel
will i be
passionate about this could i see myself
doing this for at least two to i think
even better three years
if i look ahead can i commit to this for
three years
because you know here at think media we
want to help you build a six plus figure
business
and so that does take time it does take
momentum it does take commitment it does
take work and so you're going to want to
make sure not only that the proficiency
is locked and the profit is locked but
you also have that passion element and
this is why it's cool to brainstorm 10
even 20 different passions and look for
the thematic overlap because once you
find that thing you're like that's the
sweet spot man i'm passionate about it
i've got some experience in it there's a
solid business model for it let's go
but there's one more warning and one
more pitfall and that is the passion and
profit without proficiency and that's
going to lead to failure
if you're not self-aware enough that you
don't like right now i could look at uh
and sure i could learn but i could look
at like the nft space it's it's it's i'm
kind of passionate about it i just got
my v friends series two
right i got two of those pretty pumped
you know i'm kind of getting excited
about but i have like different people i
know they know way more they put more
experience into it
nfts hugely profitable kind of niche
right now not just buying them and
flipping them but actually teaching
about them so i have a i am passionate
about it
not at the top of my passion i'm
passionate about it is it profitable oh
yeah do i really have the proficiency
and do i even care to learn to study to
research to figure it all out i don't so
the problem would be if i started like
an nft
channel
somebody else
has more drive around that topic and
already also has more learnings now
again
not to be too afraid of the competition
and in session two we're going to talk
about how to solve that because even if
there is someone directly competing with
you that's even better than you
you can still win on youtube using the
second session framework we're going to
talk about the unfair advantage
framework but
that's a huge key if you don't have the
proficiency it will ultimately lead to
failure and so uh let me know in the
comments
which
when you do this 3p framework and you
narrow down 10 or so of your passions
which one has all three which one has
all three this is how you find your
niche and you choose the best channel
topic based around your unique ability
and this might be
this might actually be a light bulb
moment in fact let me know
should i actually pivot my niche should
i change my approach should i change
what i'm doing because if you have been
struggling on youtube it could be
that you're positioned wrong if you've
been struggling on youtube it could be
that you're in the wrong niche or the
wrong niche it could be that you're not
in total alignment when you get in
alignment with your passion and your
profit and your proficiency i really
believe that the impossible becomes
possible and you can experience
exponential growth so let me know your
aha from this first session and i want
to welcome back heather and omar we want
to take some of your questions and then
uh hit like if you've been getting value
and we're going to um move into session
number three in just a bit but actually
i also want to remind you that today's
growth video live show is brought to you
by grow with video
live and so uh check out this quick
video and then we'll jump into some q a
this thing is your gateway to get out of
the thing that you complain about but
people would rather complain about how
it is than put in the work we need to
start understanding how big this
opportunity is because for everybody in
this room you will sit back in 20 30
years and regret if you didn't execute
in this era it has never been a better
time in the human race ever to actually
just go all in on you
[Music]
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to be
here
[Music]
this is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you
yeah we are so fired up because growth
video live is coming soon and not only
is today's episode brought to you by
growth video live but if you haven't
heard we are actually doing a limited
time special there's only a few more
hours left on what we're calling the
grow with video accelerator program so
in addition to a ticket to groweth video
live the event for the first time ever
we've combined our signature youtube
coaching program called video ranking
academy our camera confidence course and
if you look on screen you can see that's
also included in here is niche finder if
you you might have a lot of questions
about really dialing in your niche
basically we just covered one part of
one session
with the 3p framework and i just
recorded 16 videos in a brand new course
that'll not just help you nail your
niche but really will help you build a
profitable business in a lot of ways
it's more of a marketing and positioning
business class that really talks about
how do you
position your channel for serious profit
and really build a
high income youtube business uh this
year and beyond so this is ending soon
we just wanted to get this in front of
you that learn video 2022 if you haven't
heard about it all the details are there
uh you could get actually over 90 off on
all of our signature training and a
ticket to growth video live and so i'll
tell you a little bit more about that
later but i want to pass it over to
heather uh for any kind of questions
that have been coming in before we get
to session number two
yeah there were a few questions because
you know right when we start talking
about what they're what someone's niche
should be omar um is when it's like like
sean said you have a lot of different
niches that uh that you could be
passionate about and that's what britney
said she said well what if i have
multiple passions mine are god travel
health and wellness what advice would
you give to brittany and of course omar
we're going to be heading into session
number two and three to go even deeper
on this but but how do you help someone
choose what's right for them
yeah i mean i definitely think what what
sean talked about when it comes to
going
down the line three years i think that's
that's just one
filter that can really help like would
you stay interested enough in this
because uh the reality is is
i'm into coffee but i just don't know if
i want to go that deep for three years
and teach on coffee
even though every day i drink it and you
know here and there i'm watching content
on that but like just because i love it
and just because i am passionate about
it i that i think that time frame uh
question is is really huge
yeah and also for this one too you know
brittany uh we addressed this question
um earlier uh with inside of our
challenge and you know someone was
really passionate about disney but they
lived like states away from disney and
it's so you also have to think about the
proximity so i'm passionate about travel
but we only travel like two times a year
you know so the idea of being able to
create enough content um is a big part
of it too lisa asks uh can you be about
learning those passions my proficiency
is that i love to learn stuff and lisa i
would answer this is that you know you
like sean said you want to be a step
ahead of who you are teaching so maybe
you are five years into being i'll say
like a real estate agent i'm not sure
what lisa's passion is or what her
proficiency is in but maybe you're
learning how to start a real estate
company well there's people that are
just starting that you could be helping
or maybe you bought a new house and you
want to start a diy channel and you want
to show your process of doing that it's
still figuring out though who you're
helping in that space so just learning
in general is still very very broad
because there's a lot of things that you
could learn and so figuring out how you
can actually tailor that into helping
someone specifically omar irene had a
great question um because you know there
are a lot of different uh um
there are a lot of different experts in
this space that are trying to help
people figure this out and aaron on
demand who actually is going to be a
speaker this year at grow with video
live so if you want to come irene and
see aaron on demand on the stage at
growth video live teaching her secret to
success um
you can at
learnvideo22.com but irene's asking omar
you know uh aaron on demand's advice
really is like figure out that avatar
that target person that you want to help
and so for her specifically it would be
like moms and how to address running
your house effectively health and
wellness diy omar does that all count
under one niche
well i think i think it's more or less
something that happens over time after
you have decided what your stuff is
about um because what happens over time
is that you know i would say the spill
the spill or the overflow effect comes
into play so you know when we focus just
straight in on tech or like cameras and
stuff you know we're talking about what
we're using cameras for we use our
cameras sometimes for church sometimes
we use our cameras with our families
when we go out to the park or when you
go on rv trips and what's the best to
vlog and then it starts to be like oh
heather likes to go camping with her
family oh omar is a pastor at his church
and those things come over time but it's
still uh is it's still key that you you
dial in on that on on an avatar that
like is still looking for that one thing
at first and then over time the overflow
effect of how you tap into other areas
would would actually happen
so good uh last question and then we're
gonna get into session number two is it
possible to have multiple niches on one
channel what's our best advice for this
omar
i think the easy answer is yes it's
possible because uh you're probably an
adult and you can do anything that you
want and uh but the but but is it the
wisest thing uh now that that's that's
the bigger question and i i think the
reason why i say yes though is because
you you could have something uh go
together you know um a very famous
youtuber uh that many people know peter
mckinnon he's like a filmmaker kind of
does photography and video tutorials and
things like that he's he's looking on
starting a new show and i watched a
video where he was making a logo for it
but he wants to talk about gears and
beers
and it's about
you know equipment like photography and
cameras and things like that but then
over a beer and it's because he likes
you know ipas and you know niche stuff
niche drinks like that
and so all that to say that
the way he's combining the two is one
way you can actually double a niche and
that's just you know but thinking
through it's just a very wise thing that
he can do but uh you could totally have
like sub niches with within your niche
yeah really good i'm excited because
we're going to get into uh the next part
of this session and it's going to go a
little bit deeper into really
understanding you know how you're
picking your niche and and answering a
lot of the questions that we're seeing
coming in um someone also said i was
trying to find it omar someone said uh i
just jumped into the niche finder when
you join us inside of uh learn video
2022 you do actually get our course all
about niche finder uh going deeper into
what sean's teaching here so i'm excited
to get into this next part of the the uh
the class today sean
i love it if you've been getting value
smash the like button and uh and maybe
share this with somebody can you think
of somebody that would have that would
want some youtube strategy for 2022.
as you layer on these three sessions
it's really going to help you get an
edge and that's actually what the second
session is all about it's all about the
unfair advantage framework that makes
the competition on youtube irrelevant
it's a bold statement
but that's what we're going to be
covering with this and again this is a
part of our youtube niche finder which
you can
learn more about at
learnvideo2022.com where there's
actually 16 sessions and to that
question about um you know also
not just your niche isn't just about
what you're doing but it's who you're
reaching we actually have worksheets and
customer avatar viewer avatar we go
really deep in that in niche finder but
this right here is a framework that has
helped me
answer the question of man i feel like
there's already somebody doing what i'm
doing do you feel that way i mean
chances are like that's for sure i mean
there's it's a big world you know on
youtube there's probably already
somebody that has a channel that's like
yours or that's talking about the same
topic as yours and so it can kind of be
overwhelming and even kind of daunting
to think about how am i going to stand
out against the competition and also if
the competition's ahead of me how am i
ever going to catch up and the good news
is you don't need to if you use this
framework and it starts with there's
three levels of depth to your channel
topic once you've figured out your
channel topic there's three levels of
depth and it starts with what you do
it's actually the most shallow level but
this is the area that most people
compete so tech let me know what is it
you do on youtube
this would be like saying i review
cameras because that's one of the things
i do and you go okay it sounds like the
same as a lot of other people you know
what i mean like this is like i do
makeup of beauty tutorials all right
it's the same as a lot of other people
now this one is actually really helpful
though at least answering these
questions
you should answer the question of am i
going to be in entertainment or
education
at the what level knowing if your
channel is going to be about education
or entertainment it's kind of the two
big niches
okay and then this is also saying what
problem do i solve so jennifer's here
and she says i teach canva same as
thousands of others that's good because
we're going to talk about how to go
deeper jennifer thanks for sharing that
uh danielle's here talking about i teach
branding so do thousands of others right
but it's nice to have clarity about what
is it you do you know making it my own
diys i'm a crafter on youtube so tell me
no matter where you're watching this uh
what is it that you do
that's the most shallow level though
right and i and i'm gonna to use a
couple other analogies think about like
different restaurants
i'm a pizza place
a lot of other pizza places we're a
sushi restaurant a lot of other sushi
restaurants we sell coffee
okay well there's a lot of other coffee
places and so on the what level if you
stay there you'll probably be defeated
on youtube so we got to take it deeper
the second level is how
how do you do it now this actually is an
area that i really want you to you know
get a fresh page out and start
brainstorming about how
you can be different on youtube this is
actually a powerful level of depth
like how you do it is a
point of uniqueness that i want you to
amplify
so when i think about how you do it i
think about
motel 6 and the ritz carlton
that's a different how of where you're
going to spend the night when it's you
know when it's time to uh you're on a
road trip or you're on a vacation motel
6 how do they do
hotels and motels oh they do it cheap
which is actually a good value
proposition if you're looking for the
best affordable price you're going to go
to a motel 6. now the bed might not be
the best you might get some bed bugs in
there if you know what i'm saying and
like the carpet might be a little bit
sticky but at least at least there is
carpet and you know and and and the the
shampoo and the conditioner if you know
that motel 6 life is in a dispenser you
know i mean like you literally it's like
on you dispense it and it's probably not
the highest level
of vitamin d enriched vitamin e
you know conditioner for your hair motel
6
ritz carlton different price point
how do you do it well they call they
know your name well thank you mr cannell
for for being here today they actually
have cash in their pocket in case you
have a bad experience and they're like
i'm so sorry here's some cash for your
trouble now they can afford that because
the price is much higher but the how
they do lodging is different
so how can you do youtube
different right this goes into
how do you dress what's in your
background are you more are you more
punk or more conservative are you into
geek culture or are you really into
classic records and rock memorabilia
like are you what are the how unique
aspects of your personality that you can
amplify
on youtube that's the
how level right what is your unique
personality also what is your process so
when you say danielle says i do branding
okay cool uh but there's a lot of
different framework i'm teaching you a
framework right now there's a lot of
different approaches to how to brand
your business and so if you really want
to stand out in an education niche you
want a proprietary process and you want
a unique way of doing it like for
example at
learnvideo2022.com we're doing a special
offer right now on our video ranking
academy uh online youtube course right
and we have a unique process a seven
step the 7r framework which is our video
ranking academy system and nobody else
has this
there's a lot of people teaching youtube
nobody teaches it how
i teach it
right there's a lot of people teaching
youtube but nobody has our proprietary
process that's now been proven and we
have over 10 000 students so we have so
many people silver play buttons gold
play buttons that from from following
our how no it's also not the only way to
do it
ritz carlson is not the only place to
stay tonight motel 6 is not the only
place to eat tonight chick-fil-a is not
the only place to get chicken right you
could go to kfc
you could also go to
roscos chicken and waffles
raisin canes come on what's your
favorite chicken bojangles like you
could there's different places you could
go to get chicken so
you might be cooking up some chicken on
youtube but i'm asking you to amplify
your how what is your process how is it
different from others and what is your
unique approach and point of view
on the problem but listen
not the deepest level
that second level is going to help you
stand out but there's another level of
depth that is ultimately how you can
really make the competition
irrelevant
like the competition stops mattering
watch when you go to this level and that
is
why you do what you do
why
do you care about branding why
do you like doing diy projects why
do you do what you do here's a question
what is the bigger purpose or mission of
your youtube channel
like what are your highest values
like what
what matters to you
at the core driving your channel
and so why do you do what you do
you know when it comes to
coffee let's say there's a lot of
different house
there's the
mcdonald's coffee dunkin donuts coffee
there's starbucks coffee kind of in the
middle and then there's also like your
local hipster coffee shop right
and so they have different styles of of
where they get their coffee how they do
it etc but there's even a why behind
them i looked at starbucks's mission
statement they they want to be a third
place and their why watch this is to
inspire and nurture human the human
spirit one person one cup in one
neighborhood at a time
there's a deeper you probably didn't
know that but there's actually a driving
force behind their youtube behind their
store their chain of stores called
starbucks what's the driving force
behind your youtube channel right
and so ultimately your why and watch
this can make you become radically
different than somebody else
you know we help people build profitable
youtube channels but some people in this
in our space
they're all about all they care about is
the bling
all they want to they just want to flex
cars maybe it's just about a party
lifestyle it's just about amassing as
much money as possible just for yourself
just so you can flex but that's not to
think media vibe that is not roi
our why behind what we're doing is
because we really want to change lives
we believe money is a tool not just for
our families and our team and of course
to support
so we can pay our own mortgage and raise
our kids but we also like to give
generously we support 49 kids through
compassion international uh 79 kids at
here at think media to help them get
education and food and a safe place to
live
like we're driven by faith believing
that god wove greatness into your and my
dna and that that's meant to be
expressed and amplified there's somebody
else who doesn't it would completely
counter
would come against my worldview their
why is no god doesn't matter i'm my own
god i'm gonna do what i want it's a
radically different perspective and and
and therefore some people are like oh
sean's a christian i don't like him good
see that's why the competition's
irrelevant it doesn't even matter if we
have the best thing
like they just go i don't like him but
watch
there are some who will be pushed away
by your why but others will actually be
magnetized to you by your why because
people
follow people with shared beliefs and
people really connect with people with
similar values
so you're teaching canva and people
connect with your vibe they connect with
your why and i'm not saying you got to
get on and just tell your whole life
story i'm just saying that this will
bleed through the why you do it the
mission underneath it all like for
example talking about chicken right
chick-fil-a many know is kind of like a
a faith-based company check out their
their why
it's good chicken and good customer
service by the way
that's not going to make you unique
everything you do should be good and you
should have good customer service that's
not like we have integrity i hope so
like so that's not going to give you
unique difference your why is going to
be deeper than that
watch this they're closed on sunday
and and here is their mission to glorify
god by being a faithful steward of all
that is entrusted to us and to have a
positive influence on all who come in
contact with chick-fil-a
by the way people
get so mad that chick-fil-a even
acknowledges that god is real they give
glory to god right but guess what people
also love chick-fil-a of course they
gotta have good chicken and there's
always like a line all the way out to
the street whenever i pass a chick-fil-a
and they got the two drive-through
windows
but they're driven by a whole mission
statement that resonates with people
here's my question for you is what's
your why what's the deeper mission
what's the what's the why beneath it all
listen you're what matters you need to
do your what excellently your how is
going to give you some different your
some unique difference remember that
different is better than better your
unique way of doing it will help you
stand out but your why is going to be
the foundation under it all and never
forget that people follow people with
shared beliefs and people connect with
people with similar values
you know when i think about roi and i
think a lot of people do resonate with
think media when we talk about this kind
of stuff
our our mission
is to help 10 000 purpose-driven people
create a full-time living doing what
they love while making a difference in
the world with youtube and online video
but there's actually a phrase that we
have written in our slack and amongst
our team and we talk about it sometimes
are it actually goes on with another
sentence
and it's to experience that success
without losing your soul
and it's part of our mission
because even different than whatever
your your religious beliefs or your
faith beliefs are
we have observed
that people often times build businesses
in a mass wealth but they destroy their
family in the process
we've seen that especially in the
influencer and youtube culture that
people grow on youtube or they grow on
social media but they get burnt out and
sometimes blow up their marriage divorce
is running rampant they get into all
kinds of toxic addictions and this isn't
coming from a place of judgment this is
coming from a place of our mission is to
help people experience success on
youtube without losing their soul
because what good is it to reach the top
of the mountain only to realize you're
ultimately on the wrong mountain because
you sacrifice what matters most
so ultimately our why
is yes similar to others of course our
stuff has to work to help you succeed on
youtube that's like being good at the
what and then our how is different
and our styles may be different and
maybe you resonated with it or not
doesn't matter i'm hoping you apply this
to your channel
what's your
why
right and even beneath that the core
vision of our company is to teach
business and marketing from a biblical
perspective
so
in case you were wondering the bible is
our framework for success
we believe it's the most proven even
separate from the the faith side of it
it is the most proven and tested way of
life that has proven to produce healthy
long-lasting results over centuries now
and so a lot of modern ideologies
are theories that are not just untested
but they would actually go against my
particular world view and you go how can
you connect that to business and
marketing well you absolutely can i mean
the bible is the greatest leadership
book the greatest success book the
greatest marketing book all those
principles are in there proverbs all
that kind of stuff so that's like the
why behind our company a few otherwise
and i'm sharing some of this because i
want you to journal and inspi and write
down what is your why
what are your five to ten highest values
what do you believe to be true about the
world that even if you're teaching canva
cool
but why
even if you're doing diy projects why
like what what what's the deeper level
what's the point
what is it that moves you
if it doesn't move you you're not going
to move others if you don't get set on
fire by your why you're never going to
spark anybody else the interesting thing
about this framework is this framework
is also a key framework for starting
movements which ultimately if you want
online influence at a major level
you
and you want to create something
different than just a what channel
just the the level of depth of what
you can spark movements if you have a
strong enough why and you have enough
clarity about your deeper values and so
some of the other things that drive us
as a company we believe there's never
been a better time to build a life in a
business on your own terms
we are so passionate about that right
now and the data supports it that right
now the creator economy is going to go
from 20 billion to 104 billion by the
end of this year that's 5x growth in the
next nine months there has never been a
better time to build a youtube business
right we believe the education system's
broken
so our beliefs that's why we're doing
new forms of education we don't have a
massive lease on a hundred acres of
stone and concrete buildings with
professors who've never actually run or
built a business or whatever teaching
business we just think that a lot of
things that are in education are are
flawed and broken and therefore we hope
to change that
we are an education company but we're a
new school education company it's one of
our wise we
we believe that one of the greatest
reasons we can be on earth and the
greatest things to
attain is to live up to our god-given
potential
life is a gift god wove greatness into
our dna the fact we're even here
breathing air the fact we exist is a
gift from god and our response is to
steward the moments and minutes we have
on this planet by giving that back to it
loving our families building businesses
being productive generous
that's that's what drives us
i have another level of depth with you
though that i want to share and this is
i don't know i was going to go here but
i do have it in my notes and then we'll
get to some of your questions
here's another depth of why
who is the enemy
or nemesis to your mission
what
yeah if you want a stronger why you
should be clear on who your enemy is
what like and by the way your enemy
might be
canva channel bad design comic sans
might be your enemy you're like you
should never touch that font you know
what i mean your enemy in branding is
bad branding it could just be confusing
messaging your enemy could just be
lazy dried out chicken and you're like
you've been cooking it wrong man you got
to keep that moisture in there you know
you that you didn't you didn't fry that
stuff right your enemy might be an
ideology
it could be a person but i'm not saying
it has to actually be a person
it might be though a way of beliefs and
your youtube channel
that when you have an enemy your
channel's message gets stronger
is this too deep can we go here and so
ultimately
our one some of our enemies that think
media are greedy scammy online marketers
people who just try to shill an online
course
but don't really back it up with quality
learning quality customer support that's
why we have a whole faculty that
supports our students so we have 25
people on the think media team makes
this a lot it makes us different than
other people in the industry who slap
together an online course it's five
years outdated information and they
weren't even really
experts in it they got lucky once they
haven't built multiple youtube channels
like we're obsessed with being player
coaches and we just see too much greed
and scammy online marketers misleading
people so we're we're on a mission to
correct that do we get mislabeled sure
people are like oh you guys are just
trying to you know sean you're just
trying to sell your book well you can
feel that way but the book is amazing
and it changes lives you don't have to
buy it you know what i mean
but we're on a mission to conduct
ourselves the best we can with integrity
with we're being world class with honor
so that's some of our enemies is those
is is
our enemies is education that sucks and
is outdated
are our enemies are outdated
methodologies and and people living in
the old world when now it's the new
economy
because like the world is changing and
we got to learn new skills
um you know we we also some of our
enemies or how we feel is we feel
they're that influencers are leaders
because they're being followed
but that there's a lot of influencers
that are not worth following
and this might come across as judgey but
i'm not afraid if that's the case
i
frankly now that i'm a father with an 18
month old named sean bradley cannell
another one on the way due september 3rd
2022 named john steven cannell i look at
some of the influencers that people are
following on social media and i just go
my god
i don't want i wouldn't want my son to
emulate that behavior
these the influencers obsessed with
themselves
obsessed with their image obsessed with
materialism obsessed with greed obsessed
with with toxic you know sexual behavior
that are horrible examples that are you
know rude that are whatever and i know
that comes across judges just true
just like just
just not leaders worth following
we're the leaders
where are the influencers and by the way
i'm actually not trying to curse the
darkness i'm trying to light a light
that's why we are on a mission to help
ten thousand purpose-driven people that
actually just believe that we need to
champion values again like family and
that we need to actually raise the
standard of what a leader is and that
things like generosity and love and
things like inter integrity and
character really matter
and that values like that that's that
traditional values are traditional for a
reason because there's something about
building your life on the rock and not
the sand
and so that's where we're coming from
and so we just have our little piece of
the internet i know we're not that big i
know that we that think media is just
one small
stone in the ocean of what's happening
online
but i really believe
that as we throw our stone out into the
the river of the internet that we can
hopefully create a ripple
and that maybe that ripple will create
more ripples in your life
like and whether this is the only and
last video you see from us hopefully
this gets you thinking about being the
change you want to see in the world and
being and i know like you're like dog
i'm just trying to make like a gaming
youtube channel like what do you talk
what is the why behind my like elden
ring channel you know what i mean like
for real
but but i just think it matters that we
use our platforms for purpose
and use our platforms for good and we do
believe and we're not afraid of making
money and building wealth we believe
that that's god honoring and that we
could be generous and it can fuel the
mission and we can feed our kids so we
do want to help you not just prosper and
build a powerful youtube channel that
makes a lot of money but also develop
the character
because we want to create leaders in all
different sectors and all different
niches with all different types of
youtube channels i'm going a little long
here but i just want to ask you
what's your why
what's your why what's the why behind
your youtube channel i hope this is
helping you want to make your youtube
channel unique get clear on your what
are you education or entertainment get
clear on your how what's your unique
vibe style musical background influences
things that that you know just unique
flavor that makes you you amplify that
but then at a deep level amplifier y
and and your why
it might hit your about page on your
youtube channel it may be on your cover
it may not even be in your next video
friend like your next canva tutorial
doesn't need some long rant like the one
i'm on
this what what what the why is powerful
about is you getting serious and
actually getting clear on the values
driving your channel
like if you don't know your your your 10
values then you'll just be blown around
by whatever the opinion of the day is
what is what is the core convictions
driving your channel because the more
convicted you get and the more
passionate you get and the more clear
you get on your vision and your mission
is the more powerful your youtube
channel is going to be it's going to
help you crash through quitting points
it's going to help you overcome
challenges but what it's ultimately
going to do is it's going to polarize
people away from you but it's going to
polarize people to you you want to start
a movement you want 100 000 subscribers
you want the competition to be
irrelevant
start with why get clear on your why and
that's going to give you an edge
when it comes to building up your
youtube influence
all right let me know if you been
getting value hit the like button and uh
and i'm going to bring heather and omar
back on here and i'd love to answer some
questions uh heather and omar will take
some of those we still have the third
session coming up in just a second and
uh i also want to remind you um that uh
today's episode is brought to you by
learnvideo2022
which is a special bundle we are doing
on um our best selling uh
youtube courses and social media courses
combined with a ticket to grow with
video live
2022 happening online and in las vegas
may 23rd and 24th uh but heather take it
away i'm curious to hear what people
been asking and i'll be here connecting
with you in the comments as well as i
take a sip of some coffee yeah you know
for this session omar it was i think a
lot more of the aha moments right like
we went through the three p's first your
your passion your proficiency and your
profit but then we just got really deep
into not just what you do or how you do
it but why you do it and i really love
uh that even alex thank you alex for
being here said you know a big reason
you're so successful is what you stand
for sean since
joining vra which is video ranking
academy our signature course in 2017
you are always you've always been
consistent and i loved um that they said
that victor also said yo i joined vra
like two months ago and it's without a
doubt the best youtube course online
plus you get lifetime access that alone
makes it unstoppable so it's really cool
of art to just see that people are
resonating um even with the why that
we're doing here at think media and uh
this was really interesting naomi said
what if there's big competition
channels answering your exact particular
why why don't you speak some
encouragement into naomi because this to
me feels like a limiting belief of the
idea that other people are doing it and
they might have the same why
no for sure i i think that's kind of
where uh if you look back to what like
the the outer part of the circle being
uh the what and and the how
is is so if you feel like somebody has
like the same y as you oh it's great
especially if you have a good why you
know um
but but where you would then distinguish
yourself would be in the what and the
how and you know and what sean talked
about how does it look how does it teach
how how how's your angle how do you you
know there there's so many things
outside of just a shared why and and
just to
just to say with you you know how many
youtube channels have the same y as us
because you know you can clearly know
that like we have a pretty foundational
why when it comes to people who believe
in what we believe in uh but with that
being said that that that nonetheless
doesn't like that it shouldn't it
shouldn't prevent somebody from creating
it shouldn't prevent us from creating uh
because we have our own way of doing
something and so that's what i would
encourage you with don't don't allow
that to
allow that to actually encourage you to
add to the
you know the why of whatever that may be
because wise should be a good thing for
humanity uh but nonetheless
you would still be different in your
approach you would still be different in
how you come across and how you share
the information you're trying to share
on your youtube channel
yeah i think the way that uh canvas
classroom just said it there's always a
way to do things differently because you
are the only you there is and i think a
big part of it too comes with your life
experience that you have the season of
life that you're in um like sean was
saying just the values uh and digging
deeper into those and and really you
will be set apart when you are the one
that actually just starts to speak those
things out you know we won't know
the deeper part of your why unless you
start to really pull that out and i
think this is an exercise omar that that
is really great for people to do because
sometimes it's just in our head but when
you actually write it out like no i'm
i'm here to make a difference in the
lives of others my why is because i
believe the education system is broken
my why it like really actually just
taking the time to write those things
out you'll start to see some of the
uniqueness in your own value
of how you can come and impact the
platform omar we have so many people
that have said they've joined video
ranking academy i love billy just put
this uh joined video ranking academy
three years ago and just hit 112
subscribers literally couldn't do it
without think media you can get more
detail at learnvideo2022 i saw omar that
you were answering uh someone in the
youtube chat that was like what's vra uh
you can learn all about that over there
um is it good to have multiple wise or
is is having multiple wise good should
we refine our why into a sentence or two
i love this question from sammy omar
because i remember uh about six years
ago um shawn and i we put a meeting on
the calendar and we're like we were
gonna define our why right we were we we
knew we were gonna come up with a
sentence and by the end of it we
literally had like a page of our why uh
when it came to it and to boil it down
to you know we want to help 10 000
people um we we actually went to the
internet first and we're like what are
some mission statements right and we
just kind of got different ideas but
first thing we had to do sammy was write
out our whole why like we just kept
saying like why do we want to do this
why do we want to do this and it was
almost like peeling back the onion
layers of why we felt like this was the
right thing for us to do and then to
boil it down to a sentence or two i
think that that's a good mark to have
but it's not something you have to do
when you're getting started i think
really understanding just the bigger
picture of not just how you're gonna do
it what you're gonna do but why you're
doing it is the bigger picture and then
over time sammy you can boil it down um
to that sentence you know now omar that
we have over 10 000 people inside of
video ranking academy we're ready to to
increase the why because we want people
to go full time but now we're really
even just reevaluating because we do see
that there's a lack in leadership online
we do see there's a lack of character
online and so really understanding who
we're trying to help also um
is a big deal as well any commentary on
that
no yeah it's funny because like what
sean mentioned uh we're just trying to
help 10 000 people and we have a youtube
channel that's over 2 million we've had
yeah over 10 000 students um we we've
done a couple of conferences like i feel
like we've clearly passed that mark but
it it is more or less like a north star
you know uh and and it you know
sometimes it it it doesn't have to
actually be unachievable also you know
like it could be a north star that maybe
you never achieve but it just it's folk
you know it gives you an ability to
to reach for something uh but i would
say there is power if you can make it
something you can articulate because
because i mean even as you grow if you
start you know adding people to your
staff and i know it might sound sound
crazy but hey what if your why was to
create a place people wanted to work in
and that they'd be better because they
worked in your environment or in your
business that like having something
where that they know that they can say
uh i've heard this once that if you if
it can't be articulated then it can't be
replicated and so if you could put it in
something you know it
we're just saying you don't have to do
that but hey if you have if you if you
can write out a mission statement and it
allow it to evolve over time or
whatever you know i think i think that'd
be cool you know to do that you can put
on your wall put on a little sticky note
or something um but yeah nonetheless um
having it is just key
yeah i love what tanya said too um tanya
goes over her why with her guests before
each interview it helps us to keep the
conversation focused on the parents
we're trying to support and off of
irrelevant topics and it helps get my
guests connected right away because
they're starting to think of the
listener and not of themselves what a
great tip that tanya's doing there omar
because she really is helping the the
person coming in and i mean think about
that over and over and over just hearing
the why and understanding what the
channel is about and why she's doing it
that's such a great tip tanya thank you
for sharing that with our audience omar
we have some amazing vra students uh who
are here we've got nova who actually
says new to vra hashtag vrafam welcome
to the fam uh jay also says vra is
definitely worth it um i want the new
bonuses sean i know we're talking about
vra and some people are just jumping on
and they're not quite sure you know what
what is this and why are we why are we
talking about it today on the show
yeah um you know we are doing uh video
breaking academy is
um our
proprietary system it's our uh online
course that we created it's on about
version five now and it first came out
back in 2007 but we keep updating it we
just released a brand new update to it
um and it's an online course and that
includes a workbook um which is a pdf
download but you can print it out and
it's all built around our seven step
system uh that helps you achieve success
on youtube and not just get views but
also earn money and really build a
youtube business but what's really cool
is right now we're doing a special offer
and uh we just wanted to also make sure
that you know that it's ending soon so
you can join vra anytime you want
at our website seancannel.com
but
right now we're doing something that
includes a whole bunch of extra bonuses
which is some extra courses as well as
access to a private facebook group uh
community and so we have included video
ranking academy and our social media
accelerator course and our niche fan
finder course and of course heather and
i created together called camera
confidence and a ticket to our event
growth video live all in one special
package and to learn about it just go to
learnvideo2022.com
the key though is that the special offer
on this it's over 90 off for the
training and the ticket to grow a video
live but it ends
on april 13th at midnight and so um this
special offer uh with all of this
discounts uh is ending soon so
definitely hit up the website and we
also just added another bonus so we just
added the video creation made simple
workshop which just takes this off the
charts i mean this whole program
altogether
uh not only are you going to learn the
youtube strategy side of things and
social media strategy and all of that
but nolan and omar and chris and daisy
on the think media team are actually
doing a live workshop that you'll get a
free ticket to um in a couple of weeks
where it's all about getting your
youtube background set up right picking
out the right camera
dialing in your gear there's an
interactive portion to it where you get
your questions answered in a pretty
small group it's really really cool so
this is no extra charge this is all
included as well it's a bonus that we
added on how to create videos that look
like the pros on a shoe string budget
and so um it's exciting and ultimately
uh this whole package is available at
learnvideo2022.com
and um you know again if this isn't
right for you no big deal uh if you're
just hearing about this you're not
interested but i know there's some
people in our community that don't want
to miss out on this special offer
because we've never offered this
collection of training and courses and
coaching
at such a big discount including a
ticket to our event growth video live
with gary vaynerchuk um we've never had
a bundle like this before so i want to
make sure you get in before the deadline
and all the details are at learn video
2022. i'm pumped up heather um this is a
pretty uh cool offer we've put together
yeah i'm really excited about it and i
love being able to shout out the
different video ranking academy members
who have just joined um and really this
last section john i think just
emphasized so much for people the why
behind what they're doing and i want to
thank people for saying you know i
connected with think media um because of
the why and it's just so incredible to
see um people that want to make a
positive change on the internet but
understand that investing in themselves
investing in their learning investing in
the next season that they're stepping
into
is incredible meredith i want to say
welcome you just joined it today so
welcome to uh
to our video ranking academy um so
excited randall yeah you've got this
just press record glad to be part of the
vra fam ingrid welcome i just joined
friday okay love seeing so many people
um who are part of our video ranking
academy community so incredible uh thank
you so much john for saying that think
media is doing such a great job um and
kathy yeah you connected with think
media due to our biblical why and you
know for us that is just a key of what
we are doing john says he purchased vra
last year and it was such a blessing
thank you thank you thank you for being
a part of what we're doing well man if
you've been getting value out of this i
just want to encourage you that if
you're watching on youtube right now hit
the like button and if you're not yet
subscribed to this channel that you're
watching it on you can subscribe this is
our podcast channel this is the think
media podcast channel if you're watching
inside of a facebook group right now
we're multi-streaming all over uh this
amazing free master class that shawn's
doing three different sessions we just
went through session number one in
session number two but if you're
watching inside of one of our groups
right now and you have a friend that
needs to be here invite them to watch
this as well if you have a friend inside
the group and hit the like button
because that helps get this video out to
more people who need exactly what we are
doing thank you so much for being a part
of what we're doing and we're ready to
jump into the third session if you have
a question you could drop that question
here and uh maybe we'll pull it up so
that omar and i can answer that question
for you live here on this uh on this
live stream so sean let's jump into the
third part um but can i just say thank
you for going so deep on not even just
the three p's right people need that but
really it's understanding not just how
you're doing it not just what you're
doing but the why you're doing it and
the boldness that you had to really
share our why behind the scenes and i
hope people see that you know again
we're not sharing that in every camera
video right like you're not like this is
my why in a camera video but the values
of what we have and what we're doing
here uh really go deeper because of over
time sharing those different pieces in
different videos at different times um
so really excited for people to get into
this third part of your free master
class
well i appreciate it heather and friends
buckle your seat belt get that fresh
page out get your pencil pouch
uh because we have another session and
you know whether you got your
highlighters got some rulers i'm all
about that i'm all about that physical
book life are you about audiobooks
physical books no books
um i love uh physical books uh because i
can underline in them tab them up you
know i like physical bibles i've been
going through my uh it's a spirit-filled
new king james bible and uh this thing
is pretty gnarly man i've been my biceps
are getting stronger because this
thing's so big uh but but uh we want to
really take out
we have the very powerful third session
i don't think i've ever shared this
before
um and this will this is called our
rapid skill development framework and so
i want to encourage you this is a super
show the grow a video live
show
super show edition three sessions um and
so get ready for this because this is
gonna really help you
um
it's called session three the rapid
skill development framework and so you
can use this to learn and master the
necessary skills
for growing to a hundred thousand
subscribers and beyond
you know one of the truths about today's
world
is that the only way to win is to learn
faster than anyone else
we are in this accelerated information
age where
they've even said this i learned this
i'm reading a book called life force by
tony robbins it's all about medical
breakthroughs and it said that that even
in medicine there's a half-life that 18
months after a doctor graduates
from university there's a half-life to
their knowledge so about like a year and
a half after graduating their knowledge
is 50 outdated and then it just half
life's down so you go 10 years past them
getting out of university
and if they're not staying current with
their knowledge they're falling behind
and i know that feels like a lot of
pressure but what it just tells us is
that we have to develop the ability to
rapidly continually develop skills
and really ask ourselves the question
what are the skills that i need to
survive and thrive in the new economy
we have to become if we want to to
stay ahead and not just get ahead
we have to continuously learn i've heard
it said that
lifelong leaders
are lifelong learners
now let me know in the comments if you
would consider yourself a leader
yes or no
but whether you do or not let me tell
you today that you you need to start
considering yourself a leader
literally think about social media
an only way to succeed on social media
and youtube is to have
followers
and the only way to have followers
is if
you're
a leader because a leader without
followers is not a leader and in a
social media account or a youtube
channel without subscribers will not be
successful
and so ultimately it's not that you have
to be a leader in the traditional sense
like a religious leader or political
leader
but you want to be a leader in your
industry you want to be a leader as a
comedian you want to be a leader even as
a vlogger you want to be a leader and so
lifelong leaders though are lifelong
learners in order if you're
currently blessed to have anybody
following you
the only way to be having people
continually follow you watch is you
can't stop growing
because if you stop growing then those
following you by the way they'll either
stop or they'll leave
so so this i know it feels like a lot of
pressure but that's the responsibility
of being a leader and it comes down to
just this commitment
i just got to keep going
because that means that i only need to
be a few steps ahead today to start my
youtube channel when i started back in
2000 and
you know 10 uploaded my first video i
started teaching i made a video in my
car
talking about how to build a video
editing pc i know like 10 times more now
but i knew
enough then to start
and people who knew nothing about
building computers were like man this is
very helpful
so i just was sharing my answers for
where i was at but watch the only way i
could be where i am today is if i didn't
stop growing it was a commitment to
growth it was a commitment to
development so here's the question then
how do i rapidly develop the skills
necessary
for growing on youtube to 100 000
subscribers and beyond
and we've created this framework that is
the rapid skill development framework
and it starts at the tip with the
strategy with strategy
so so the tip of the spear if you will
is strategy what does that mean it means
to win on youtube you got to have the
right system you got to have the right
tactics you got to have the right plan
maybe you've looked up a video how do i
get views on youtube and someone shared
a tip or a couple tips of how to do it
you need that
you gotta have the right strategy
like a failing strategy will mean that
you ultimately fail
so what is your battle plan for winning
on youtube what are the tactics and by
the way there's a difference between
tactics and strategy a tactic is like
one thing like write a good title but
you're never going to win on youtube by
just writing a good title you need a
cohesive strategy
and so what we've learned though
is that strategy is the tip of the spear
you're not going to cut through the
noise if your strategy isn't solid but
strategy is only one piece
of the puzzle the second thing you need
is psychology
then and here's
this one's so much more important
because information alone is not enough
you don't need me to convince you of
that because we literally live in the
age where information is at our
fingertips
on the other side of the philosopher
google we can ask any question and get
the answer
information is becoming more and more
common
and so
the
you maybe have heard that knowledge is
power or information is power that's not
true
applied
knowledge is power
so you don't just need the strategy
you actually need the psychology what
does that mean it means the mindset and
the will and the determination and the
discipline to execute on the strategy
the reason i know this right is is that
if it really comes down to it
if we were to ask ourselves right
do we know how to be healthy
do we really need a new book on it now i
buy new books on it
but if you really boil it down
it would be eat healthy and exercise you
know what i mean like if
it doesn't matter if it looks pretty or
not when i when i exercise it does not
look pretty when i run i'm like i'm like
a hunch kind of hunched over i'm 6'1
kind of lanky like it doesn't look great
but i'm burning calories
and and and it's good to get out and
move
but
if you're like me you still might be
watching that infomercial and you're
like oh wow there's a little device for
just three payments of 29.99 and i can
just connect these electrodes to my abs
and have six pack abs in a couple months
it's not real that's that's not true the
the thing is it's having a strategy but
you actually have to apply it what is
that that's the psychology piece
so the psychology piece this is remember
the rapid skill development and this is
talking about this is just stuff that a
lot of people wouldn't really share with
you because i even watching this you
might be like why don't you teach about
thumbnails why can't you just tell me
the secrets of the algorithm and talk
about analytics we cover all that like
we teach all this that stuff but friend
is that really the most important thing
or is actually the most important thing
is you getting motivated and getting off
the couch and actually punching fear in
the face and pressing record
is the is it is the information the
thing you're lacking or is it actually
the mindset and the courage to not be
afraid of what other people think and
actually share your voice powerfully
online
is is is it really the strategy and the
tips is that your biggest challenge or
is it the
unbreakable will and confidence to crash
through quitting points so the
psychology piece is like having a growth
mindset
the belief that you control your own
ability and can learn and improve that's
the key to success right yes hard work
and effort and persistence are important
but it's not as important as having an
underlying belief that you are in
control of your own destiny
and i've personally learned that i've
needed to do a lot of mindset work
a lot of belief work
so that i could get myself to take
action
on the strategy and the information i
have
i was just like doing my morning routine
today and i was looking at my bookshelf
and i was looking at all the books i
haven't read yet the information is
potential power but i need to not just
read the book i got to apply the book
psychology right actually putting it
into action so confidence healthy
self-esteem a resilient mindset that
will beat adversity a strong mindset
will increase your drive strong
psychology and mental toughness pushes
you towards your goals it shifts you
into possibility thinking and it shifts
your perspective on things a disciplined
mindset is what's needed to cut through
the distractions of modern culture you
do not need endless information you need
the confidence to take massive continued
action
psychology
psychology but that is not the only
piece
yes we need solid strategy
we need a plan we need to understand how
youtube works
yeah we also need
a strong mindset and strong psychology
but there's another piece and that's
community
that's community
so community
is this piece that we have now studied
and this isn't just apply to youtube
this applies to business this applies to
like life it applies to like staying
married what's so fascinating
is who you're around really matters the
community around you really matters
like they discover charles tremendous
jones said it this way you're gonna be
the same person
in five years as you are today except
for the people you meet and the books
you read
that's how he put it
you're gonna be exactly the same place
you are today in five years
except for like basically the
information you learn
but also the people you're around
it's just true
walk with the wise become wise
bad company corrupts good character
the fastest way to change yourself is to
hang out with people who are already
where you want to be
the more most powerful thing i've
learned out of strategy and psychology
but how to hack those two things is
community
and i've learned that getting around
people in some cases well sean i don't
know how do i get around people but i've
learned the way i do it listening to
people's podcasts reading people's books
attending events
being in a community where the
impossible becomes possible where the
impossible is logical for some people
around you they might only see defeat in
cynicism and it might feel like you look
around and all you see is people
struggling we look around and all we see
is people succeeding
it's not because we're disconnected from
the true hardships in the world it's
just when you hang out with people who
have a growth mindset who see
possibilities who overcome challenges
who are not delusional who just
acknowledge challenges and see every
challenge as an opportunity that has a
seed in it for for greater growth for
that every problem
is an opportunity that's entrepreneur
thinking because you need problems to
solve entrepreneurs solve problems for a
profit but do you are you around a
community that is
encouraging you with that and giving you
those types of
mindset growth and and and it's kind of
that thing where we talk about this when
it comes to community there's a lot of
stuff that's actually more caught than
it is taught
it's one thing to just read words on a
page but this is why i love being
immersed and around somebody where stuff
just kind of rubs off on you where
courage just kind of rubs off on you
where seeing possibility just kind of
rubs off on you what you listen to
matters what you read matters what you
see matters who you hang out with
matters
and investing in that this has been what
i've learned now watch
i've learned that strategy
is about 20 of the equation
now the tip of the spear matters
sharpening the tip of that arrow is
critical to cut through the noise and
succeed on youtube but it's only about
20 of the success
people over emphasize how important it
is
like if your strategy is not right
then you will stay stuck however
think about
the unopened course material on your
computer or on the cloud think about the
unread book on yourself right
think about the the unapplied note you
wrote in your journal that's why that's
why when you really just think about it
you go okay like i needed to know the
thing to do but the kind of more
important thing is that i actually do it
which is why psychology is about 40 of
success
more important is actually applying what
you know to do and therefore having that
mindset having that uh having having the
will and the mental toughness to
continually apply it because the other
thing is is that strategy is never
instantaneous so so you have to have the
mental toughness to know oh i tried once
and it didn't work well no kidding you
and everybody else well i uploaded one
of my favorite things that happens when
it comes to us doing channel reviews and
doing youtube coaching is people ask
questions we're open to every question
as people you know share what they're
struggling with in the in the chat and
in the comments we're open to hearing
and listening and we have big hearts of
love and empathy but one of my favorite
things people will say to me is like hey
sean
i've been trying this youtube thing and
it's just not working
that is my favorite invitation to click
through and look at their channel
sean i just don't get it i tried your
tips and they're just not working
really sir okay let me check let me
click through and look at your channel
and here's what i see on the channel
i see no cover art
their avatar is a d the letter d it's no
they didn't upload an avatar picture the
youtube logo
i see that there's six videos on the
channel one was 12 months ago the next
one was 10 months ago they uploaded one
three months ago and none of them have
thumbnails one's a weird gaming play
through then one is them sharing their
tips on success and then their newest
video is like a youtube short of their
dog playing in the snow
sean
it's just not working bro you're just
not working it
like you can't you could say it's just
not first of all
you haven't even applied the information
second of all you haven't even been
consistent applying the information you
uploaded six videos in the last 12
months six different topics six
different formats and you're not even
doing half the best practices
applying the actual knowledge
and i understand that that takes
psychology and that's why actually doing
it is about 40 percent of success
but the other 40 is that community piece
it's that community piece because i've
actually learned personally maybe you're
different that i've learned personally i
can't succeed alone i have to lock arms
and get other people around me you got
to know that something kinetic
happens when i'm around heather taurus i
dream bigger she helps me reframe like
it may seem like i'm always in a
positive state of mind maybe not
sometimes you're like you're kind of
sometimes a little bit saucy sean but
like
like you you know you'd be surprised i
need omar and mel and heather who speak
life into me and hope into me when i'm
exhausted and when when i'm not seeing
uh you know tired eyes rarely see a
bright future and there are definitely
moments where i start getting super
cynical and i'm seeing a negative future
not a positive future community you need
people in your circle
but more than that like it's like when
my friend uh when sometimes i'm feeling
down i turn on my friend peter voog who
made a mixtape and i start getting in
the right mindset when i'm feeling down
i i turn on uh you know maybe a sermon
from my pastor jaben chavez and i start
getting in the right minds that's
community
i got people in my world
that can actually keep me on track you
might be fine alone i'm not
you might be fine by yourself i'm not
i need community
and i i would you could go to the back
of my book youtube secrets read the
acknowledgements and see the people
listed there who are instrumental in my
success some of peop some of them have
never met
it's because i bought their courses i've
bought their books i listened to their
podcast that's my community they're
helping me get my strategy right and my
psychology right and sometimes
see we get accused sean you've said this
before
sean why not change something new um not
already seeing this video on think media
i can't believe you guys are repeating
yourself on think media well we need to
keep repeating ourselves sir because
you're not doing it
oh yeah you already posted this video
well how about you actually post a video
how about that oh i heard you post this
in another video why don't you actually
because i've learned this that
repetition is the father of learning and
the mother of mastery
so that actually being in community
where you're hearing the same things
over and over getting your mind right
getting your psycho
psychology right and reinforcing the
strategy is critical
for cutting through the noise standing
out on youtube and experiencing massive
success
so this framework is the rapid
development skill development framework
on how to quickly learn and master the
necessary skills for growing to 100 000
subscribers and beyond
you got to get your psychology right you
got to get your strategy right you got
to get your community right and notice
that community and psychology are almost
like the foundation that everything's
built on and strategy is the tip of the
spear
every piece matters they're weighted
differently though but when every piece
is intact
you're going to experience incredible
success and listen if you only if you
have like kind of weak psychology like
you're like i'm not very confident i
need a lot of help building my
confidence but you have the right people
around you or you're in the right
community and again that might be a
facebook community that might be
it's
oftentimes multiple things it could be
local community in your local city but
it's also online communities that you're
a part of it's it's right now i mean
you're a part of even if you are never
part of any of our uh courses or
programs and you never join anything i'm
super grateful you're here in the chat
right now on one of our facebook pages
honor you i mean this is as much as we
can do a community that's free
our deepest level of community is in our
private facebook group on video ranking
academy and then on top of that it's the
strategy
and even if you have a 12
good strategy
your psychology is only 22 but you have
a strong community
then you
you add those together and you're still
gonna get momentum if you can max these
out i got the best strategy i'm getting
my confidence right my mindset right my
growth mindset right i'm
intentionally by the way it's a key word
being intentional about this stuff
i'm intentionally pursuing
world-class strategy the best in the
world
getting my mind right and building my
mental toughness and confidence
and getting around a community and this
is a journey i've been working on this
for the last 10 years and i work on this
rest of my life
but these are the pieces to rapid skill
development and and as we've learned
these
as i think media we've discovered these
we asked ourselves
you know how uh
this being true how could we create
a
community
where we could do our best at offering
people all of these elements and that
ultimately is what our special offer is
all about
it's about
the fact that you've got the strategy
inside of the course if it's only 20
it's critical
i believe it's the best course you ever
take on youtube
but you also have one of the things we
created is called our camera confidence
course
and heather and i
researched and studied
science-backed psychological and
confidence-building truths
that are not just things like makeup
background what clothes to wear how to
look right on camera raise the camera up
a little bit it's slimming you know like
some different things all the practical
things but also the mindset stuff
but then also the fact that we realized
we needed to create a community
where we could actually realize iron
sharpens iron and we do that in a
private facebook group and then more
than that and again again you might say
aha i see what you did there sean
it leads perfectly into
the fact that you have a solution for
that well it should
i mean that's that's the
is why we're doing grow with video live
is because we recognize we wanted to
create a place where you could learn the
strategies
but you could also get your mindset
right to be around people thinking
bigger
but you could also be connected to a
community and form relationships that
can last a lifetime and that's just one
piece it's what we do in our products
and our programs because we've learned
friends we have
hundreds of pictures now
of all our success students sharing the
financial results they're getting we
have
a slack thread we have multiple slack
threads called vra
testimonials and in our slack threads
i'll show you i have to switch my screen
up and it just goes on and on and on and
we have
these right here vra just keeps um is it
on screen vra just keeps winning there's
andy sharon about bra just keeps winning
so there's kylie and here's another one
andy's saying let's go and here's more
there's from twitter and here's megan
sharing about the results she's getting
and there's dr andrea furling getting
369 000 subscribers and it just goes on
and on this was on march 25th and now
we're going march 24th here's videos
sent to me in dms here's what's
happening i'm a hundred thousand
subscribers friends our program has the
greatest success rate out of any program
in the world
it just does pretty bold claim like we
just have i i'm i'm so connected to
other course creators so we just and why
is that because i didn't just make this
up like this is based on research in
personal development adult learning
theory that you need the strategy you
need the psychology and you need the
community so we said how do we actually
create that to give all of our students
the best possible chance of success
can we do it for you we can't
it's on you
ultimately you've got to watch the
videos you've got to stay committed to
taking notes you've got to do the
workbook you've actually got to be
engaged in the facebook group you've got
to do all the stuff
but i know of nothing else like it that
gives you all the elements problem is
a lot of people give you the strategy
but it's only 20
there is some good mindset training out
there but are they giving you enough of
a community to continually build the
mindset
and is there even a community you're
like oh they promised a private facebook
group but it's completely dead and
there's no one in there and i don't even
blame the people that are letting you
down in those areas
because a lot of times they just haven't
actually built up a business model
that's that committed to customer
success so they haven't hired a faculty
and a team to support there's no way i
could do there's no way i could deliver
all this to you
i can't
but sean and heather and omar and chris
and andy and victoria and mel and isaiah
and caleb and sam they can
and nolan
and steph
and kyle that's the think media team
the mission we're on we're so serious
about that we wanted to make sure all
the pillars were in place
to give you a place where you can
quickly learn and master the necessary
skills to grow into 100 000 subscribers
and beyond on youtube
and i hear me as well and if if if this
offer this learn video 20 if this offer
is not right for you well then don't do
it
like just find these pieces somewhere
because this remains true regardless you
got to get the strategy right get your
mindset right and get plugged into a
community i am completely
i'm excited that we might not be the
right community for for you
but i want you to win regardless so you
need to find a community somewhere
and you need to intentionally build up
your mental toughness somewhere
and you need to pick uh i'm this isn't
even the only methodology for youtube
there's a lot of cool people out there i
get i speak at all the youtube events
like they're all my friends there's
different approaches all i know is that
we have the most consistent success with
our students because it's the most
practical youtube framework that i know
about
sure there's the unicorn mr b strategy
but it's a lot it's a lot rarer for
people to succeed kind of going that
viral
approach to things as opposed to brick
by brick intent based content that we
ultimately teach inside of vra and so i
hope this serves you and what i want you
to do is think about and now rate
yourself how are these areas in your
life
the application item
is do you have confidence that you have
the best youtube strategies and
information to execute on if not you got
to go get it
rate yourself in psychology like do you
feel like your confidence your mental
toughness your drive your ability to
crash through quitting points your
possibility thinking that you always you
spend almost no time in negative
thinking and you quickly bounce back
when you get down that's called
resilience how quickly do you recover
from kind of being knocked down or a bad
day how many good days in a row can you
connect and how many bad days can you
eliminate that bad days it's not it's no
longer you don't even have a bad day a
bad day is unacceptable it's a bad
moment just because of mental toughness
resilience bounced back he goes that
sucks this is hard
but it doesn't do me any good to wallow
in anxiety or worry i'm gonna bounce
back from this it's a mental toughness
thing and then community do you have the
right people around you friend get these
pieces in place because there's there's
5x growth happening in the crater
economy over the next nine months and
this is going to be necessary because
the only way to win is to learn faster
than anybody else
and so you need to be quickly learning
and mastering the necessary skills for
crushing it on youtube
if you're getting value today that's
session number three smash the like
button um and let me know what your aha
moment was from this last session and
let me know if there was anything that
stood out to you that you're like wow i
really need to work on this area which
one you need to work on the most
strategy psychology or community let me
know and
we're going to do more q a in just a
second i'm going to bring heather and
omar back on but i do want to remind you
we are weeks away from grow with video
live this is the growth video live show
we're going to do some q a in just a
second and so we'll be right back do you
want to get in the room with experts
like gary vaynerchuk patrick betdavid
vanessa lau pat flynn chalene johnson
and more and would you like to meet
hundreds of other creative entrepreneurs
just like you well then do not miss the
chance to get around creators and
business influencers at growth video
live 2022 conference you can actually
lock in your limited discounted tickets
at
growethvideolive.com or you can click
the link in this post or in the
description now if you want to learn the
best new strategies for getting views on
youtube and the most proven and
profitable ways to grow online then do
not miss this life-changing event you
can join us in person in las vegas or
virtually from around the world secure
your ticket at grossvideolive.com and
take the fast track to dominating the
next decade not just with youtube but
with video go to growthvideolive.com or
click the link in this poster in the
description to secure your limited time
discounted ticket
now listen actually i'm so excited for
growth video live but that is not the
best url unless you're watching this on
a replay sometime in the future yes the
event is coming up but the event website
is not the best place to get this
limited special offer it's actually
learnvideo2022.com where you can get not
just a ticket to grow with video live
but also
the online courses that are going to
give you that continual learning that
you can start immediately so really the
best
uh what we've put together here is this
we've put together the the fact that um
we have a special offer it's called our
grow with video accelerator and inside
of there is our video ranking academy
program our niche finder program and a
lot of other cool stuff
and what we'd recommend is that you join
that special offer right now where you
can get over 90 off of the total value
and you can start learning immediately
you can you know print out your workbook
you start getting into the content and
start getting results right away and
then realize that in a few weeks whether
you join us in person in vegas or
whether you just watch online through
the online experience of growth video
live you're going to be reinforcing
those strategies learning new ones from
all of our guests
and um that you'll be able to
also get around even virtually there's
gonna be like breakout rooms and stuff
virtually as well as in person of course
that's a different level of the
experience um and all of that's
happening in just a few weeks but then
all of this continues because right now
we're offering lifetime access to these
training materials and to our private
community which is called our video
ranking academy private facebook group
and so all of that is in one place and
if you like the idea
of having a world-class community the
world-class minecraft mindset training
as well as the best strategies that are
also
you're giving lifetime updates like we
just uploaded 25 new videos to video
ranking academy it's incred it's
incredibly current and we're rolling out
three uh three more updates throughout
this year three more blocks where we're
dropping just fire content that will
absolutely blow your mind all of that's
available at
learnvideo2022.com now here's also the
cool thing this is backed by our 100
satisfaction guarantee and it's called
our think media satisfaction guarantee
you have 30 days to try everything out
and it's a no question sassed money back
guarantee so you can have the confidence
to know is this legit will this work for
me is this even what i think it is
honestly it actually removes all risk
and it puts all the risk on me
because ultimately you have 30 days to
try everything out and whether it's 29
minutes from now or 29 days from now you
email us and you just say sean i'm not
happy and here's my commitment if you're
not happy
i'm not happy period
i am that committed that this program if
you value your time and you want to and
you're serious about growing on youtube
and using social media video to build
your personal brand and build your
business or create a business
i'm 100 confident that this is the best
offer on the internet period the best
training on the internet period and i
back that up by giving you 30 days to
ultimately try all that out so heads up
this is all ending
um at midnight on april 13th that is at
the time of actually going live that is
12 hours from now and so there's a
limited time to get this of course these
products are available separately or you
could pay more to join just video
ranking academy but to ultimately get a
ticket to grow a video live as well
as our best youtube course and all the
other bonuses all the details are at
learnvideo2022.com and if you have any
questions about that let us know as i
welcome back heather taurus and omar
alta corey and uh to talk a little bit
more too about rapid skill development
and any questions that you have
yeah and uh love what people are saying
here um uh omar about growth video live
randall just said uh girls video live is
gonna be amazing yes garyvee
patrickbetdavid alex for mosey wow yeah
randall is coming to girls video live
really excited about that mathen's
actually going to be joining us
virtually which i'm really excited about
but i had this question that came in
omar and i know uh that kirian's been a
part of what we're doing here uh when it
comes to even the niche and if you have
a question you can ask us here we're uh
we're getting these questions live here
on
the show so um you can ask your question
uh either on youtube or facebook or if
you're watching but um would i go and
look at a niche like happiness
motivation mentoring to me omar that's
actually the uh the goal of the channel
it doesn't actually it's not actually a
niche specifically right like who are
you helping carry on is where i would go
with that question um are you wanting to
help young mothers uh with understanding
happiness motivation and helping them
find mentors are you trying to help baby
boomers um do that like who are you
trying to helping who are you trying to
help is where i would go with that
question and yeah and even
yeah i would say like what was what just
happened moments ago with sean in the
you know this entire
hour and 30 minutes but even like the
last session sean is
motivating and he's mentoring but we're
talking about youtube so i think yeah
sometimes it it sometimes like the idea
of getting into that i would say is just
going to be a very long journey but if
you can find something that people are
looking for
like tangibly need help with then you
could mentor them and then you can
motivate them um in that and you would
be looked at as i think that's what's so
cool about youtube is there is no
permission no one's you know you don't
need to ask permission to promote
yourself and that with that comes
authority and then people open up that
door and allow you to mentor them or
coach them or whatever
so so good omar uh this is a great
question um i'm kind of confused there's
so many different brands and courses and
programs think media growth video learn
video 2022 what is the best course sorry
so vanilla your your best uh your next
step your best next step is to go to
learn video 2022 maybe sean can pop that
back on the screen all that comes when
you go to learnvideo2022.com
uh inside of that is where you're going
to find a bundle of items uh here that
we teach at think media which is the
overarching brand that we have here and
part of that is our video ranking
academy which is our signature online
course and group coaching community
where you can go step by step to learn
how to grow your youtube channel and
make money online and then grow with
video live is actually our online and
in-person conference so that is uh that
is a
a one-time event that will be happening
and you can get all the details it's
very well explained over at learn video
2022
but yes we we have a lot of different
brands because we have a lot of
different ways that we can help you
different programs that are right for
people at different stages
in their journey
do you need to niche down in your genre
if your genre is broad omar
yes
you do just because
uh if i just had a travel channel and it
was just travel
um i would again it'd be a very long
journey
but if you can you know find the nuance
of traveling whether that is
backpacking travel in the himalayas uh
or
you know travel in the us
or
travel along
the
pacific north coast highway what is that
highway 101 one yeah pacific coast
highway pch um yeah but but just but
just dialing it in a little bit more um
i think in our world you know where
think media
may seem general
we filter you know 85 percent of the
content through a youtube filter it's
not the best camera for videos no it's
the best camera for youtube
it's not the best lighting for
cinematography no it's the best lighting
for youtube and live streams so i think
within the generality of your niche just
to like go a little bit deeper and like
i like like to think of it like a filter
what what what's the filter pass-through
in which you're you're trying to
generalize your information
so so good randall so excited to be
joining the amazing think media team
with the bundle um and uh let's see
definitely signing up and i had another
question that came in here about
uh can you make a full-time income from
youtube with a lifestyle channel
absolutely ashley there are actually uh
signalfire just released a brand new
article that said that being a content
creator is one of the fastest growing
small business types and the lifestyle
channels are part of that you could be
making a full-time income making over
six figures so like even full-time
income omar can seem like a very wide uh
range of saying you know a full-time
income in the us is like 50 000 you can
do that on youtube and what's great is
there's potential for that to be even
more it can be over six figures it could
be into the seven figures with a
lifestyle channel i think actually what
you would have to decide is how
committed are you how committed are you
to growing your youtube channel because
if you're just posting a video here and
there if you don't really have the
strategy with it the psychology with it
the community with it it can be really
difficult to get to that full-time
income
just on your own and not really knowing
the path forward so i would just
encourage you ashley that if you're
saying i'm committed to youtube i'm
committed to making this a full-time uh
income for myself and my family then i
want to encourage you to join us at
learnvideo2022
where you're going to get access to all
of our programs that will help you do
exactly that plus you'll get the access
to grow with video live that ticket so
that you have that as well uh driven
says welcome new vra members that is one
thing i love so much omar is the
community aspect of video ranking
academy you've seen that really um by
being a part of it for so long why don't
you tell everyone just a little bit
about what that community is like inside
of vra
yeah i mean if i could break it down
like i guess the the first uh part of
the community aspect if you do join is
is the private facebook group and this
is a private facebook group of people
who all want to you know grow their
youtube channels and build businesses
around their youtube channels uh but
there's a community level at the student
level there but we don't just like throw
people in a private facebook group and
let them fend for themselves we actually
have people on staff community that are
at think media that are involved inside
of that community and so they're they're
doing things like thumbnail tuesdays or
um you know milestone mondays and we
have these things that even just
push push our students to actually look
at their analytics or even push them to
create content so that they can be a
part of these you know uh threads where
we're we're going back and forth and so
i think it's it's really a holistic
community approach that we give our
students and i actually think it's
insane like i think it's insane that
like once you join uh our programs that
literally you have lifetime access and
lifetime support and like sean mentioned
he has studied the greats he has studied
the people that are in network marketing
and they have their own communities and
stuff but i i truly believe and and i've
also seen myself that nobody does it and
puts i guess you could say the money
where their mouth is when it comes to
community building and a lifetime access
to something that not only is always
ongoing and that that people are
watering uh but also lifetime access to
updated content that like sean we're
constantly adding to the vra uh you know
course also and so with that being said
all that like it's just it's so much
goodness but that's how the community
aspect looks like when it comes to um
the private facebook group we have
so so good omar i'd love to know what
was your aha moment from today's session
and i'd love for the people who are
watching right now let us know what your
aha moment was did you have a particular
aha moment uh going through that session
no for sure i i definitely think
sometimes in my head i think we get we
get a little caught up in strategy um
and that's probably where we either you
know get uh paralyzed
uh but when it comes to actually like
putting in what you're learning you know
when when sean was talking about
repetition uh when sean was talking
about actually putting in the reps i
there there i wrote this down once
before but there is no rep there's no
replacement for repetition a lot of
people ask me how do you get better at
video how do you get better with
uploading making youtube videos how do
you get you you have to actually do the
work you actually have to put into play
what it is you're learning and so i do
want to clarify that if you jump and
join what your you know our programs
that learn video 2022 and you learn
everything and you absorb it all but it
doesn't actually get put into practice
that you will actually miss out but i
think i think the aha is really in the
psychology and community aspect of
building a channel because although you
know becoming a content creator is one
of the fastest growing small business
types it is a very social isolating you
know journey where you can just be in
your own cave trying to do this yourself
and how important community is even
beyond the actual genuine thing you're
doing like he's talking about like our
community we have at our church is so
big uh but then the psychology part for
sure just just actually putting into
play what it is you're learning um but
that's kind of my from that session
really good yeah mine uh i love this
what uh marina says uh who you're around
really matters and i've seen that really
happen over my uh career that you know
the people the rooms that i'm in matter
the people i'm around matter and i want
to be in the rooms with people who are
inspiring and who um are speaking life
into you and who are seeing the bigger
picture you know versus
complaining or having negative uh
thoughts i think it's really important i
love that this is not i actually read
that earlier i read that earlier today
in proverbs it's a walk with the wise
and become wise yes hello somebody
yes uh surround yourself with others
uh that in that that uh
that will deter you and that it would
lead to destruction
okay one more time because i interrupted
you i want you i want you to get that
one out
no just surround yourself with the wise
those who walk with the wise become wise
it's in proverbs the proverbs of the day
really good consistency and repetition
are so important christopher you could
have not said it any better um you got
to make videos you have to be posting
videos and and really getting those reps
in you that's how we learned how to do
live video and be able to you know
handle all the things that are happening
on a live video so really really
important that's proverbs 13 proverb of
the day aha was the moment changing your
mindset moment changing your mindset
awesome
i had an incredible future in front of
me because of the mentorship i have now
accessed that's amazing omar they love
you omar they love you lifelong leaders
are lifelong learners i love that so
much and uh putting everything together
today uh is what is what they're gonna
try to do really excited for what you're
going to do go past one why and go
through more and uh taking all off
them into it and taking all of them into
the account so jen love that your why is
what you're going to be doing and taking
action so so excited hey if you would
like to i'm going to bring sean back on
uh closing us out but we are excited
because uh we do have that special offer
of learn video
2022 is where you can go if you'd like
to get into um our amazing youtube
course and coaching bundle if you have
other questions we're going to be here
in the chat as well after this but sean
take it away
yes can we show some love to heather and
omar l tech
rory um elta corey and uh really
appreciate you for being here smash like
if you got value today and if you're
just joining um this was kind of a
unique thing we did there's three
different sessions and so um definitely
catch the replay and watch those but as
a reminder our special offer available
at learnvideo2022.com
is only available until midnight tonight
it's april 13th wednesday april 13th and
it really is you'll see all the details
there you'll see
you know oh there's so many different
things someone said too well there's
actually a lot if you want basically the
body of work we've created at think
media our best youtube training our best
social media training our best training
for how to find your niche and a ticket
to grow a video live it's all in one
bundle and that's what's ending is the
chance to get it all is one you can buy
it all separately but imagine just
having it all together it's like getting
the ps5 and four dual shock controllers
and last of us two final fantasy vii red
dead redemption 2 and eldon ring all in
one bundle imagine for one discounted
price and so we're we're doing that with
our training and we're putting it all
together at learnvideo2022.com
and this is the grow with video live
show so every week we're going to be
streaming so make sure you turn on
notifications if you're on facebook or
you're on youtube on our podcast channel
watching this make sure you're
subscribed make sure you like the page
make sure you got notifications on we're
going to have some special guests omar
and heather and i are going to be back
we're going to be adding value every
week
and so we appreciate you and are really
grateful that you are here
and with that click or tap the screen to
actually check out one of our favorite
think media podcast episodes every
tuesday we have a think media podcast
episode that is entirely free for you so
click or tap the screen to check out the
last video podcast that we uploaded and
until next time keep crushing it keep
smashing it and we will see you in the
next growth video live show
peace